For this video I’m going to show you how
to convert a few fistfuls of empty bullet
casings, into a decorative set of multi-purpose
paperweights. Using a bit of styrofoam, a
little ingenuity, and a whole lot of fire
power.
To start this project, you might want to check
the legalities of making these “artfully
disguised” paperweights, where you are.
Brass Knuckles are banned in quite a few places.
And if that’s the case where you live, then
don’t make your knuckles, out of brass.
Alright, let’s kick things off, with few
handfuls of bullet shells.
I salvaged these brass casings from a local
shooting range, so there aren’t any bullets
in them, and you can tell the primer’s been
fired as well, which is important.
Now let’s fire up the “Mini Metal Foundry”
I showed you how to make in a previous project,
and toss the empty shells inside, to get them
warming up.
Now a lot of people have asked whether this
improvised backyard foundry can actually get
hot enough to melt brass, and the answer,
is yeah, it’ll melt brass no problem.
In-fact you can melt copper, silver, and even
gold without any trouble at all. And the best
part is, you can do it on propane.
Propane burns clean, costs less, and melts
metal way faster than charcoal does. But you
do need a specially designed jet-torch, to
balance the fuel-to-air ratios, and make it work properly.
This is the design I came up with, and I’ll
show you how to make this “Gas Blaster”
torch, in another project video.
Now it’s only been about 8 minutes, but
peeking inside the foundry, you can see that
amazingly, the brass casings have already
melted down, and liquified completely.
That’s really impressive, considering the
melting point of brass is around 1,700ºF,
and the foundry was cold, when we started
less than 10 minutes ago.
The liquid metal is bubbling because brass
is a mixture of copper and zinc. And at these
temperatures, the zinc is starting to boil,
and vaporize right out of the mix.
We don’t really want that to happen, but
luckily, there’s an easy way to stop it.
I went to the dollar store and picked up a
bottle of cockroach killer, which you can
see is actually just 100% boric acid.
If we sprinkle a generous amount of the white
powder into the soup of molten metal, we can
sit back, and watch it do the dirty work for
us.
Boric acid helps clean the metals by absorbing
impurities, and helping prevent new oxide
layers from forming on the surface.
And if you put it in before you fire up the
foundry, it’ll melt your metal even faster,
and help keep the zinc from boiling off as
well.
Ok the crucible’s full and everything’s
completely liquified, but before we pour the
metal, it’s a good idea to scrape any gunk
off the top, and clean it up a bit.
I typically use a pair of old steel tongs,
for skimming the slag, but you can use anything
you want as long as it’s made of steel,
and you don’t ever plan on using it, for anything else.
I went ahead and poured these liquified bullet
shells, into a beat up old muffin tray, then
knocked the ingots out and let them cool,
into a stack, of mini brass biscuits.
Now to transform these heavy metal muffins,
into fistfuls of defensive jewelry, we’ll
need a styrofoam cutting template, like this
one I made in photoshop.
If you want a copy, just check the description,
and download it for free.
Glue the paper template to two layers of dollar
store foam-board, then carefully, cut it all out.
A cool trick to cutting the finger holes,
is to simply heat one of the leftover casings
and push it straight into the foam.
With just a touch, you’ll see it melts perfect
circles, all by itself.
An even better way to slice foam, is with
a hot-wire foam cutter. Like this one, I made
from cheap and commonly available materials.
This “Styro-Slicer” uses electricity to
quickly and accurately trace the edges of
paper templates, without cutting the paper
itself.
That means you can use styrofoam to make just
about anything you can think of, so watch
for how to build the “Styro-Slicer” in
another project video.
Ok now that we’ve got our foam knuckles
carved out, the next step is to glue two styrofoam
risers to either side of the base, and bury
it in a bucket of sand.
I filled a small trash bin half full of common
play sand, then gently nestled the foam knuckles,
down into the loose layer on the top.
From here, all we need to do is add a bit
more sand, to fill the bucket the rest of
the way, then give it a little shake, so the
sand levels itself out, exposing the foam risers at the top.
Now we’re going to need a way to funnel
the streams of molten metal into the foam
risers, so try packing a little wet sand on
top, then shaping it into little craters, a couple inches deep.
Do one for each side, and with that finished,
it’s time to transform our styrofoam investment, into solid brass.
Remelt the brass, then carefully pour the
glowing hot liquid into one of the craters,
where you can see, the extreme heat vaporizes
the foam in an instant.
This allows liquid metal to flow down and
fill all the empty spaces. And if you quickly,
and carefully pour the other side as well,
you’ll have a much better chance of success, on the first try.
The metal only needs around 5-10 minutes to
cool down, so feel free to pull it out and
take a look. Just be careful not to touch
it, because it’s still extremely hot.
I cooled mine in a bucket of water, then chopped
the risers off with a hacksaw, and just like
that, we’ve got ourselves a crude, but very
cool looking, brass casting.
Now just for fun, I wondered how this thing
would look cleaned up a bit, so I clamped
it in my bench vice and worked it over a few
times with metal files, and some fine grained
sand paper … And BAM, there it is.
Just like that we’ve got ourselves a smooth
and shiny brass paw, which for some reason
feels really comfortable, and strangely empowering.
This piece of defensive jewelry has a really
nice weight to it, and because it was designed
to fit my hand, it really does feel amazing.
But it’s important to note these aren’t
intended to be used as weapons.
Instead, I like to think of them more as multi-functional
paperweights, buffed to a mirror finish, and
designed to occupy my workspace, as “dangerously
elegant decor”.
Now just to push the boundaries a little further,
I stopped by an alternative clothing store,
and picked up a spike studded choker collar.
So I guess you could say things are getting pretty serious.
Let’s unscrew six of the aluminum spikes,
and screw them into the brass workpiece instead,
just to make the whole thing, look absolutely
mental.
The six holes were drilled using a 5/32”
bit, then tapped with a #10-32 thread so I
could secure each of the metal spikes tightly
to the brass.
It’s beautiful, it’s dangerous, and it’s
incredibly durable. And to go one step further,
I went ahead and made another one, the exact
same way.
Well now you know how to transform a few handfuls
of scrap bullet casings into a custom pair
of fancy, and dangerously decorative, solid
brass paperweights.
They are a lot of work to make, but the feeling
of creation and accomplishment, is all worth it.
By the way if you’re up for another challenge,
try making my “Mini Master Sword”.
I cast this “Golden Sword” from styrofoam
as well, and you can find the template for
how to make it, it in another project video.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you’ll like some
of my others.
Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com